الذكاء الاصطناعي تطور بشكل سريع وربما
مخيف ايضا حيث تتزايد المخاوف من تاثيرات
التكنولوجيا الحديثه على البشر هذه
المخاوف دفعت مجموعه من المشرعين
الديمقراطيين بالكونغرس الامريكيه لوضع
ضوابط قانونيه على ذكاء الاصطناعي كشف
موقع اكسيوس عن اخر خطط للنائب
الديمقراطيس لتفعيل قانون يجبروا صناعه
تكنولوجيا الذكاء الاصطناعي وضع شاره تؤكد
ان المنتج ليس صناعه بشريه سيطلب مشروع
القانون من مصممي روبوتات الدردشه كشات
الحصول على اخلاء مسؤوليه لاعلام
المستخدمين بما قد ينطوي عليه من جوانب
سلبيه جراءه لاستخدام سيكون هذا المشروع
وهو اخر حلقه في سلسله جهود الكونجرس
للتاكد من ان التقدم التكنولوجي لا يسبب
اضرارا اجتماعيه بحسب السينات فان اعلان
اخلاء المسؤوليه يعتبر نقطه انطلاق جيده
للحد من مخاطر الذكاء الاصطناعي لكنه ليس
بالحل السحري
بحسب رايه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات